you mentioned Andrew Breitbart and I was
wondering because you know you get that
thing with like the bill hicks's of the
world the people who die young they
always get a lot of credit and that's
what happened with bride but what do you
make of his impact on Politics on your
own was he a big influence for you and
what would you make of his impact on the
culture we were good friends I mean the
thing with Andrew was and I said this to
a lot of people I spent a fair bit of
time with Andrew and you know helped him
with a bunch of big projects but if you
met Andrew for five minutes you knew him
about 95 as well as I did he kind of
reserved himself for like one close
friend who's a business partner Larry
Sullivan and his family
um but you know everybody else who was
kind of the same too it was if you met
you for five minutes you got his entire
life story you knew everything about him
he was very enthusiastic uh the the
impact that Andrew had on a lot of
people was he really helped connect a
lot of people there are a lot of people
in different places where he helped make
the connections which is why he actually
was one of the founding forces not just
behind Breitbart but obviously he was
involved in Drudge Report and also he
held found Huffington Post right so like
half the internet was founded at least
in some large part by Andrew uh it
wasn't as though he was sort of Guru you
go to you know for like life advice it
wasn't really like that it was he was
somebody who you went to if you want to
be connected with another person and
then he had sort of an interestingly
eclectic view of the world every he was
really a lot of fun he was really a
sweet guy that by the end his image had
changed so much because of the Dynamics
of politics that you see him doing the
war kind of the war hashtag War you know
the angry pictures of Andrew and all
that sort of stuff here in the end that
fundamentally is not who Andrew was and
if you talk to anybody who know knew
Andrew for a long time the image that
comes to mind of Andrew for most of us
is that there's a YouTube video where he
was literally just rollerblading around
Santa Monica just talking to people and
he'd like take people like let's go to
Applebee's and just sit down with people
and talk with them that was Andrew's
unique gift is being able to connect
with people that way and he he never
thought that he was better than anybody
else which is why I think he was able to
connect really well with people but as
far as sort of the the kind of General
contributions connecting people and then
the the argument that he made which
wasn't unique to him but he sort of
popularized the culture was Upstream of
politics and that you need to get
involved in the culture fight which I
obviously this has some pretty
significant ramifications
[Music]